was soll ich sagen die außenseiter
obwohl eins kann ich kurz erwähnen sie
erklären nämlich warum es so lange
gedauert hat bis zu diesem ersten großen
interview und warum sie so ein bisschen
bammel hatten also bis am wanter
ja da wurden wir nur ein bisschen kommen
halli hallo
ich freue mich riesig meinte ich was
soll ich denn fragen was soll ich denn
fragen sie nicht ich glaube schon wie
ist die lage
wir sind damals roland emmerich hat
gesagt ja ich hab da was
20 dezember partien bei christoph zu
hause das haben ja viele gesagt aber
bist du auch der meinung dass die welt
untergehen nein glaube ich nein ich
glaube nicht wir müssen
also ein raumschiff
er sagte man die welt wird untergehen
ich denke ich denke wir sollten einfach
mal wetten dass ist richtig dann ein
paar stellen bekommt oder so weil wir
jeden tag redet der vom ende der welt
und das hier wirklich einer mancher
denkt waren aber ich meine das ist schon
so oft gesagt worden dass die welt
untergeht ich glaube nicht dran aber
das macht passiert ist hier so gross zu
glauben ich weiß schon warum wir hier
sind wir haben buchstäblich das 7 kurz
jahrmarkt
product placement gehen oder körper ist
nie seit er auf die idee gekommen ein
buch zu schreiben
also die idee hatten wir schon lange
eigentlich nur hatten wir erst mal nicht
die zeit dazu ich habe meine ausbildung
gemacht damals vor einem jahr bin ich
jetzt fertig geworden und er hat noch
kein verlag und bewusst noch nicht wie
so was funktioniert und dann kam eine
verlag auf uns zu haben uns gesagt okay
jetzt haben wir keine zeit das war noch
meiner ausbildungszeit und ich habe
gesagt nein das funktioniert nicht und
dann bin ich fertig geworden die haben
uns noch mal angeschrieben und
habt ihr dann nicht manchmal angst
gehabt jetzt ein buch geschrieben ihr
habt einen riesen film gemacht eine
stunde und 40 minuten
ihr macht aber auch weiter eure kurzen
videos song party in alles mögliche habt
ihr nicht manchmal angst oder oder
anders gefragt wie schafft das euch
nicht zu verzetteln
keine ahnung wie stellen sich fragen
glaube ich gar nicht wir machen einfach
wir probieren viele sachen ausprobieren
die gerne aus also ist auch interessant
zu erfahren wozu bist du überhaupt
als youtuber ist es natürlich ganz
einfach in so eine schublade gesteckt zu
werden du bist einfach ein comedy mensch
oder unterhaltungs mensch und uns war
das schon immer wichtig einfach unsere
ideen raubs zu ziehen und zu gucken was
können wir noch und das ist das wissen
viele unserer fans oder lila die wir uns
mal gesehen haben oder auch einige
videos von uns weil das jedes mal was
anderes dabei hoffe ich zumindest dass
darüber kommt das ist was anderes ist
für viele ist es vielleicht auch so
gleiches gleich auf seinesgleichen habe
ich gesehen und runter ihr seid doch
oder welche fällt jetzt keinen bilden
gehörter sagen aber ja so und so
ich hab's vergessen nein also so ein
film so ein projekt ist für top youtuber
eigentliche selbstzerstörung weil und
das kann auch sehr viel zeit und
die desto länger hin zuschauer wartet
desto größer war wie wird das jetzt wie
die erwartung groß dabei haben wir nur
zu zweit gemacht das ganze projekt er
das merkt man bei uns auch in den
letzten videos das ja auch an zuschauern
verloren haben abonnenten wir haben die
zwar noch da die abonnenten aber man
merkt auch dass die videos nicht so
aktiv gesehen bewertet werden oder
kommentiert werden und das ist auch ein
ergebnis daraus dass wir auch so eine
lange pause gemacht haben uns zeit
gelassen für das buch für den film und
so kam noch dazu und dann ist klar man
merkt das schon aber gibt es dann nicht
zu denken wenn man in so einer situation
an abonnenten verliert weniger views hat
habe ich was falsch gemacht weil wir
wussten unsere anfang einer dass wenn
wir zum beispiel zwei herbert videos
machen das wird die zahl die klicks
haben die das drei vorhaben als von
diesem film wir wollten einfach machen
weil ist uns am herzen lag solche themen
auch anzusprechen und diesmal nicht
exklusiv für diese schule rock sondern
auch wie die außenseite ja bekannt ja
das haben wir gewusst das war schon
bewusst wir wussten schon bei vielen
videos wie das ungefähr ankommen wird
wir haben noch viele sachen
auszuprobieren so ganz genau was da
werden leute ausgelegt und uns dafür
hassen aber das haben nun auf sonntag
für uns gemacht also wir machen
natürlich unterhaltungs videos wie die
leute damit sie was zu lachen zum
nachdenken aber auch zum teil für uns
war dass unsere leidenschaft ist und
wenn diese leidenschaft kollidiert mit
dem was die zuschauer erwarten
kommt da nicht irgendwann so die schere
im kopf das dürfen wir nicht machen dass
dörfer machen oder ist euch das wirklich
egal wir machen nur die sache nicht die
jungs youtube verbieten würde wir
versuchen zumindest die unsere videos
wurden schon gesperrt einige erbrachten
eingestuft usw aber wir versuchen
natürlich zu gucken dass wir jetzt uns
nicht ausziehen oder irgendwie über
sachen reden die vielleicht gar nicht
gut ankommen würden weil natürlich eine
gewisse vorbildfunktion haben die
sollten wir nicht vergessen und die habt
ihr in eurem buch umgesetzt die
vorbildfunktion ist
placement
ja genau aber auch mit so neuen sachen
und die neuen sachen ausprobieren reicht
doch neue menschen damit man dream und
im gleichen zug fährt dann
wirst du schlecht weiterkommen in dem
buch haben wir vieles beschrieben also
es gibt es handelt sich um ganz
verschiedene themen wir haben versucht
das natürlich auf eine witzige art und
weise zu gestalten so wie man es kennt
aber eher sind auch versteckte
botschaften drin und sachen die auch
ernst gemeint waren es ist natürlich
eine kunst dann daraus herauszufischen
was jetzt ernst gemeint warum was nicht
aber ich glaube einen menschenverstand
sektor schon also einige sachen sind so
absurd und soja das kann man gar nicht
einmal gegenstand einen wunderbaren tipp
das auto war das rennen das war glaube
ich um verlieren eine sekunden ganz zum
schluss das heißt abspann
der luft sind super also sind ja witzige
tipps fürs leben drin die man auch
befolgen sollte aber die nicht ganz
ernst gemeint sind aber sind auch ganz
ernste themen an einigen tipps ich sag
mal so wenn sie um ersten sex geht dann
super tipp ich habe ein paar tipps ja
schon ich habe einen kommentar gelesen
vor kurzem vor drei tagen glaube ich von
dem mädchen hat geschrieben ja toll ihr
buch hat nicht voll enttäuscht ich habe
das schon alles hatte schon ersten sex
alkohol hier und ich bin 14 konnte ich
den 14 nein gar nicht
wir werden unser bestes gegeben um
menschen vor den bösen zu retten aber
das funktioniert nicht weil natürlich
jeder hat so seine erfahrung wo steht
das mit der kindergärten haben
kindergärten wahrscheinlich beim kinder
gegangen mit dem verlag ja ja doch genau
das muss beim kindergarten ja jedes
beiseite 49 laut geworden es kann sein
dass auch wo ist es ja genau wenn du ein
junge bis dann hör auf von deiner heißen
erzieherin zu schwärmen wenn deine zeit
gekommen ist wird ihre leider schon
abgelaufen sein und du wirst die oma
nicht mehr flach legen das ist das ist
ja das war schon ein war das direkt die
idee so was zu machen dass ihr sagt hey
wir sind vorbilder und das müssen wir
auch machen wir müssen was witziges
machen aber wir sollten auch sollte auch
warum schon klar und zwar schon bewusst
dass wir das das ja auch diese rolle
nicht übernehmen zum teil dass leute
sagen dann okay die gucke ich gerne die
kenne ich schon lange nun was die sagen
das wird schon richtige sein freut euch
den wohl in ihrer haut
ziemlich
schauen ja es ist immer wieder ein neues
eine neue erfahrung neues gefühl da raus
zu gehen und die leute erkennen nicht
dass es immer wieder aufs neue die sind
auch ab und zu schüchtern wenn die leute
leute auf uns zukommen wir wissen nicht
was sie mit den reden sondern sie sind
auch ganz normale menschen wir kommen
manchmal auch gar nicht genauso wir
stehen auch nur so da und du wirst nicht
was die frage sollen wir wissen nicht
was wir sagen sollen und machen ihr
fotos und das weiß ich wie damals bei
burger king kommt einer mit der kamera
und füllt uns fängt alles einfach so zu
füllen und besitzt so beim essen und
also kann ich euch weiter filmen
und da geht so langsam zu
und verschwindet der dunkelheit das
machen wir ganz
genau ob das pärchen war der kfc kam
auch einer werden mit dem ein foto
gemacht so gesagt okay warum nicht und
dann kommt dann auch mal kann ich euch
beim essen fotografieren nur uns so beim
essen ohnehin das nicht mal er drauf ist
auf dem bild und das ist schon heftig so
was also das mit so was kommt da auch
nicht so schnell klar und sachen die uns
schon passiert sind im wäsche geklaut
wurde und warum war ohne licht mal
kommen sie dann an einem wäscheraum war
das einfach so einen externen wäscheraum
in unserem haus war das nicht das
warenhaus mehrfamilienhaus in einer
wohnung da und unten dann noch eine
wohnung und unsere nachbarn haben den
anscheinend reingelassen oder die oder
das und das an alien ist ja das hat
etwas mit genommen von unseren klamotten
fallen
das gefühl und dieses gewissen als für
mich war das schon krass ist das hat
mich schon mitgenommen das nimmt da 1 1
auch sehr mit psychisch glaube ich also
mich hat das schon ein bisschen runter
gezogen aber ist und das sind so momente
die ich vielleicht nicht unbedingt sehr
schön sind aber wir sagen auch immer das
gehört dazu wir sind halt menschen des
öffentlichen lebens aber habt ihr denn
da keine routine inzwischen entwickelt
das ist jedes mal wieder was neues
menschen stellt dann irgendwelche fragen
die du vielleicht noch nie gehört hast
oder sagen dann okay lass uns einen
trinken und dann hast du auch was
anderes formen dann weißt du nicht wie
du das team vermitteln sei es und er
versteht das nicht ist dann beleidigt
wenn du sagst nein ich habe keine zeit
und sagt aber kenia uganda schwein ist
bist du ja gab schon ein
unterschiedliches gab es ist schon mal
passiert schon öfters vielleicht aber da
kannst du das auch nicht jedem klar
machen dass das duo auch nur ein mensch
bist mit deinem problem und das darauf
zeit braucht für dich ich kam nach nach
der arbeit nach hause da standen leiter
vor dem haus ich war fix und fertig so
nach elf stunden arbeiten nach
überstunden kommst du halt richtig so
nach hause und die stehen einfach mal
mach mal einen witz machen so hey und
ich habe das auch schon versucht aber
dann sag ich ihnen okay ich will jetzt
rein ich muss schlafen wo man bisher
schon so weit also das ist halt schon
manchmal ist es auch essen das ist auch
traurig für mich zu wissen natürlich ich
enttäusche die jetzt im moment es geht
nicht anders würdet ihr manchmal
wünschen dass da was er die videos
machen könnte aber das nicht wäre
nein ich glaube wenn sie das schon
machen dann ist es das richtige ich war
gerade noch der in dem film wo du
erzählt hast einmal liege ich im bett
und auf einmal so drang in der nacht
scheint eine
herbert
herbert wissen wo du wohnst du liegst du
da und ex team was wir fühlen es war das
vor billig
herbert
ich klingele gleich an deine tiere oder
klingelt also so wie du man hört das
heißt wir gehören das zweite wir müssen
am nächsten tag noch arbeiten gehen
hhv ist herbert war
herbert so dass das ging ungefähr eine
stunde lang
es kamen auch zu uns leute aus der
schweiz das versuchen wir sind ja nicht
nur kinder sind auch über 18 jährige
heranwachsende die schon ein
autoführerschein haben und die lizenz
zum nerven
passiert hat
habt ihr die möglichkeiten
zum thema privatleben jemand kennen zu
lernen
eine freundin zu finden oder ist das
fast nicht mehr möglich da durch nicht
oder wenn wo lernt wie wir ihn kennen
oder geht ja anonym in singlebörsen nein
also wir sind jetzt auch nicht so frauen
aufreißt es ist so seit damals trotzdem
hätte auch gern eine freundin oder ja
schauen aber wir kommen noch gar nicht
dazu die machen ja auch sehr viel
wie du gesagt hast nicht mehr möglich
ist es auch nicht also möglich ist es
schon wir sind dabei auch nur menschen
das heißt nicht weil wir jetzt gerade
die und die sind und lust ein paar leute
kennen heißt es nicht dass wir dann
ausgehen können sagen die du dich will
ich haben dann kommen sie mit damit das
soll es aber nicht wir sind auch nur
menschen mit unseren gefühlen sind noch
ziemlich schüchtern sogar im normalen
leben wenn du nicht vor der kamera sind
aber die möglichkeiten wie normale leute
in normale jungs haben haben wir auch
wir gehen auch ab und zu aus und lernen
mädchen kennen aber dann funktioniert es
nicht entweder wegen der zeit oder weil
uns nicht verstehen diese dauer sehr
spezielle charaktere würde ich sagen
also ist es auch schwer mit uns klar zu
kommen glaube ich nicht jeder ja aber
wir könnten eigentlich noch mit
russlanddeutschen zusammen
zu sagen
da sind sich bringt also vielleicht
irgendwann vielleicht doch versuchen
dass er auf den punkt zu bringen also
wir sind auch komplizierte menschen ich
glaube viele youtube oder fast alle
youtuber sind natürlich etwas anders
heißt so der normale und wir haben unser
hohes wissen so noch die kinder im kopf
ein bisschen ist ein bisschen verrückt
wir sind auch manchmal angepasst werden
so etwas nicht passieren so die was
manchmal manchmal aber auch richtig
kaputt weil wir so viel machen und weil
wir unterwegs sind und das kann
natürlich auch nicht jede frau und dann
auch irgendwie erleiden oder damit klar
kommen und da muss man natürlich auch
durch und der besucher nach derjenigen
die damit klarkommt und die das alles
toleriert und sagt das finde ich toll
was gemacht werden unterstützt und auch
mal sagt er gut das war stehe ich ich
kann nachvollziehen und davon gibt es
halt auch nicht so könnt ihr euch denn
vorstellen da fangen jemand zu haben
also schlägt ein buch hier geht durchaus
aber könnt ihr euch natürlich ja
irgendwann sollte da schau ich will zwei
kinder und ein mädchen
der traum geht glaube ich nie in der
füllung du wirst drei mädchen kriegen
ich habe zwei töchter das muss doch die
schule sind
aber ich habe halt und das ist eben
wirklich was ihr auch sagt ist es
wahnsinnig wichtig dass man jemand hat
der das toleriert weil ich bin ja auch
ständig auf achse und ich sage immer wir
youtuber haben ads also
aufmerksamkeitsdefizitsyndrom und manche
haben doppel abs aber ich finde es ist
ihr doppel ads oder ein paar ads
also at es ist ja nie würde ich nicht so
bezeichnen uns ist das ja bei uns ist es
ganz was anderes wir mögen ja diese
aufmerksamkeit eigentlich gar nicht wir
haben damit angefangen aus leidenschaft
so um unseren freunden zu zeigen was wir
so drauf haben mit unserem geilen kamera
schnitt und so haben wir ein paar videos
gemacht und auf cd gebrannt dass die
postfächer reingeschmissen ist halt
sorgen gefangen deshalb hat es heute
noch nicht gab ihr habt da gab es noch
nichts 2004
2003/2004 habt jetzt erstmal warten hat
ja mal den witz hier wird die sendung
kannst du auch als video kassetten
verschicken das habt ihr gemacht die
haben wirklich zeichen jetzt mit wohnt
uns ging es dabei um die erfolgreich zu
hören und fame zu haben jetzt hat sich
so ergeben mit der zeit weil wir auch so
gerne gemacht haben und gerade das ist
vielleicht das problem gewesen dass wir
mit so vielen sachen nicht klar kamen
als wir diesen erfolg bekommen haben
weil das war für uns eine ganz andere
welt die leute erkenntlich plötzlich auf
der straße die schreiben zehnfach
zehntausende mails die so gar nicht
beantwortet ganz ja wir haben nie ein
manager gehabt und haben immer noch
nicht und das ist echt werden den leuten
das zu vermitteln dass vorbei dass das
damit ihr das verstehen dass du gar die
möglichkeit das nicht hin zu setzen und
10.000 mails zu beantworten und so
weiter aber nochmals allerdings hat denn
youtube
oder hat das video machen euch geholfen
oder oder ich sage mal nicht sagen der
golf ist das falsche wort
unterstützung dabei gegeben eure
persönlichkeit zu entwickeln weil ihr
sagt ihr seid ihr wirklich außenseiter
gewesen das ist ja viel wärme kommt ja
nicht von ungefähr schüle ich heute auch
wehren aus hätte es gehört halt dazu
natürlich die
möglichkeit dass mehr richtungen was
deine den charakter angeht zu entwickeln
und es ist immer aufregend was neues
auszuprobieren was videos angeht und man
entdeckt auch jedes mal wie eine
neugeburt das heißt wenn du etwas dem
wechsel was du niemals in dir gesehen
hast und du sagst du scheiße ich habe
nicht ich habe es nicht erwartet dass
ich so was in mir habe so so in der art
dieser seite dieses spezielle seite zum
beispiel diese ernste seite die würde
ich niemals für also früher die würde
ich niemals sagen dass ich ernst wird
oder über irgendwelche sachen ernst
schreiben kann
aber zeiten ändern sich
ja also ich will auch sagen dass es dass
wir außerhalb sicherer geworden sind
durch die videos also wir waren ich kann
von mir sagen dass ich schon sehr
schüchtern war bin zum teil noch als ich
nach deutschland kam da konnte ich die
sprache nicht richtig und ich war auch
sehr schüchtern dann kam nicht aus mir
raus so zu reden ich dachte diese ich
hatte nie im leben und wie einigermaßen
fließend deutsch reden das war noch vor
hier findet ja und dann durch die videos
hat sich zu hause ein bisschen titel
dass ich dann angefangen fließender und
schneller zu reden klar mache ich immer
noch unsere sprachfehler und dann bleibt
man macht ja man hat sein handy ab und
zu aber
trotzdem hilft aus einem so
selbstsicherheit zu werden weil du weißt
da sind leute kinder hinter dem monitor
hinter der kamera sagen hinter dem
monitor die dann auch sagen über das das
ist okay du hast dass das macht sich
vielleicht auch sogar schon bald so wie
du bist wir sind halt so man kann das
auch nicht wirklich von einem tag auf
den anderen ändern viele konnten sich
natürlich habe ich ausländer verpisst
euch wo ihr herkommt wo auch immer aber
damit müssen wir leben also wir müssen
natürlich auch gucken dass wir
vorankommen dass wir auch besser werden
auch mal was unsere sprachkenntnisse
angeht aber ja dass das ist eine frage
der zeit also hintern in zehn jahren 20
jahren sind die augen perfekte deutsche
ja wobei die deutschen lieben ihr akzent
die liebe mehr leute die mit akzent
sprechen auf zu haben die engländer sind
oder russen die lieben uns ist es
manchmal peinlich ja wie ganz ehrlich
uns das ist manchmal peinlich und das
lachen aber wenn ich sage dass ich so
ein komplex aber ich mag keine fremden
kameras also wenn ich weiß dass jetzt
einer kamera von anderen aber dann werde
ich manchmal den kopf um also durch
richtig also dann verliere ich meine
selbstsicherheit
ich bin seit nur gewohnt dass ich weiß
dass meine kamera ich fühle sich du bist
mein baby streicheln sie schallt ein und
es geht los und bei fremden kameras da
steht eine fette fette kamera hat so ein
großes lob also so große linse wie
meinen kopf und man weiß nie was also
was da abgeht also wie das funktioniert
ja sowohl walt disney mäßig
also ich bin oft noch unsicher aber das
geht nur so dazu zu dieser entwicklung
das war einer der gründe warum ich nicht
interviews machen wollte ich war auch
der grund dafür dass sie ist keine
interviews gab weil ich bin es nicht
gewohnt ich mag diese art von
aufmerksamkeit nicht ich habe angst mich
selber zu verlieren dadurch
das heißt was wollt ihr denn dann in der
zukunft machen also wissen wenn du eben
ich werde daraus erst war sehr positiv
ihr habt dadurch den weg aus vielleicht
nahe ecke plärrt mir das letztlich noch
erzählt and wäre
genau hier auch genau die gleiche
geschichte die kochen muss man gar nicht
oder gar nicht
gesagt auch wenn das nicht gewesen wären
kasachstan wäre ich alkoholiker geworden
hätte geklaut und er hätte das nie
geschafft und youtube hat man wirklich
weitergeholfen also das ist doch schlimm
so ein schlimmes ende hätte das nicht
also ich war auch schon immer gut in der
schule ich hätte da schon irgendwas gibt
von ja ich hatte schon immer so
interessen wenn ich mich mit irgendwas
beschäftigt habe dann habe ich das
durchgezogen ich hab' ich habe auch
angefangen zu studieren los land als
sportlehrer ich würde sie sollte sport
trainer sportlehrer werden auf jeden
fall was auch ziemlich spannend aber
dann hat sich das herausgestellt dass
wir umziehen finde ich fand ich auch
cool und neue erfahrung oder menschen
kennen zu lernen warum nicht es ist halt
es kommt immer darauf an wie deine
einstellung ist es kommt gar nicht
darauf an wo du wohnst oder wurde
geboren es gibt leute die nach verkauf
gewachsenen trotzdem zu irgendwas
gebracht haben zum beispiel dieses einem
modell das aus amerika geflüchtet ist
gibt es alles auf der welt also ja und
es kommt natürlich auch immer darauf an
was will der mensch überhaupt in seinem
leben erreichen auch seine eigene
einstellung was wollt ihr erreichen wo
es ist vieles geplant also ich will das
nicht am fahrrad ist dass vieles geplant
wir arbeiten die damaligen mehreren
videos ich glaube die leute merken auch
dass die mal wieder einer von uns kommt
dann acht gelassen dass monaten weil so
vieles an stand ein mit projekten film
und buch und umzu was ich schon gesagt
habe aber wir arbeiten an weiteren
projekten auch geheime projekte zum
beispiel arbeiten mit einem künstler
zusammen der auch angebote bekommen hat
von weltbekannten stars wie david guetta
zum beispiel aber der will auch mit uns
was machen aber ich gehe das durfte ich
eigentlich gar nicht verraten aber dann
kommt noch später was dazu dass rwe und
videos sind geplant und vielleicht
irgendwann auch wenn die zeit zeigt wie
ein eigener film was weiß ich also es
kann
also was tun wir uns nicht noch einmal
an also wenn dann noch ein kurzfilme
sind wir immer dafür bereit aber so
langen film wenn dann sparen wir die
energie und lassen einen kinderfilm raus
weil das ist ja auch schon einer zeit an
lasst sie nicht früher gab es ja auch
schon mal
ja und da sind immer noch die einzigen
film also auf youtube habe ich keine
mehr gesehen was deutschland angeht da
sind ja wirklich einzige firma die in
deutschland es gibt darunter wenn dann
wollen wir eine produktionsfirma haben
die eier hat also die wirklich was
probieren will
man schauen was schon eine folge der
zeit denke ich mal trotzdem nochmal
einmal die frage wohin ihre reise geht
konkret jetzt das aber zum beispiel beim
bewerbungsgespräch wenn immer gefragt wo
siehst du dich in fünf jahren ich würde
auch noch fragen seid ihr in zehn jahren
noch macht er noch youtube-videos also
wo geht die so was hab ich sag mal wenn
jemand der karriereplanung sind ja leute
die machen studieren und sagen und dass
ich meine karriere planung mit 60 bin
ich vorstandsvorsitzender von siemens
was stellt ihr euch davor oder lasst ihr
euch weiter ich sag mal so von den
ereignissen oder
wollte es organisch angehen also
entweder ihren anstalt
eine eigene produktionsfirma so wichtig
wie irgendwas eigenes oder
also der standardspruch wäre die lassen
uns wissen aber
alle
produktions wahl ist ja schon mal einen
ball also ich würde fast sagen wir
lassen es darauf ankommen und man kann
echt so wir sind nicht so menschen die
sie gerne in zukunft sehen und irgendwas
plan also klar planen ein bisschen auch
neue sachen zu entdecken neue sachen
auszuprobieren aber vielleicht jetzt in
zehn jahren noch youtube nicht gegen
oder auch diese unterhaltung die wir
gerne machen wir das dann nicht gewinnt
dann machen wir was anderes also wir
machen das wirklich nur solange es uns
spaß macht und wenn wir dann irgendwann
wirklich das nicht mehr machen können
weil es einfach so einfach gespielt und
nicht authentisch rüberkommt und dass
wir uns zwingen müssen das zu machen
dann machen natürlich was anderes aber
das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen was wir
dann machen vielleicht
also ich hatte schon interessanter film
zu schneiden okay so zuschneiden nicht
nehmen zu machen wo wir schneiden nicht
dabei zu sein dabei zu drehen weil ich
einfach nicht noch fragen zum schluss
bitte
ihr habt das ja mal als hobby angefangen
was ist das für ein gefühl wenn ihr
videos macht er ist das hobby ist das
beruf ist das verboten ist dann ist es
wie eine krankheit also es ist wie eine
krankheit man kann man weltmeister
werden du etwas neues erfinden aber das
rad kann man einfach nicht neu erfinden
muss manchmal auch zurückgehen wir
wollten auch so charlie chaplin der
style ausprobieren und so sachen aber
wir sind nie zufrieden also nie wir sind
wir wirklich zufrieden er vor allem also
wenn er sogar videos schneidet was wo
alle hinten pendants ist gras das ist
richtig geil
wir müssen was weißt du was machen was
anderes was neues es muss immer was
neues sein und damit das schaffst du
selber in dir drin ein problem weil dort
wir haben sogar videos zu verspielen wir
haben ein neues video mit herbert aber
wir wollen das nicht stellenweise nicht
zu verhindern sind da sagen wir wissen
sogar wieder etwas ankommen
internet
macht krank und gemacht von also ist
heilt auch von anderen seite ich will
sagen das macht anders wir sind krank
krank würde ich nicht sagen wir wissen
schon anders als jetzt ein mensch der
sich als normal bezeichnen würde aber
auch überhaupt keine frage
zurückzukommen würde ich sagen dass das
natürlich auch zum teilen beruf geworden
ist von uns weil wir es mal so wir
dürfen zwar jetzt nicht als partner über
die einnahmen reden aber wissen jetzt
alle dass das die größten youtube das
als beruf jetzt mittlerweile machen und
das ist natürlich eine tolle tolle sache
die uns passiert ist dass wir mit
unserem hobby quasi auch unseren beruf
ausüben können aber im endeffekt das ist
ja immer noch unser hobby weil wir
würden die wie das nicht machen wenn
wenn wir jetzt auch nur aus dem wie
viele sagen aus dem geld grund ihr die
geldgeilen macht das novelle geld wollte
aber dann würden uns natürlich auch
nicht hinsetzen und so ein richtig
aufwendiges video machen wir machen
viele aufwändige videos ich glaube die
leute die ein bisschen gesetzen die die
wissen auch denn die sehen das auch
sehen dass auch alle produktionsteile
also die die nehmen ist auch nicht mehr
mir war die sagen ihr seid nicht mehr
real oder sowas
weil die die haben immer noch die
vorstellung früher haben die jetzt zu
zweit es gemacht und jetzt haben die
also richtiges team was wir immer noch
nicht haben weil wir so wir wollen dass
das weitermachen wir stehen auf die
sache die selbst gemacht sind
der ruf beruf hobby und leidenschaft
krankheit als leidenschaft schrägstrich
krankheit sagen weil wir es gar nicht
funktionieren aber fahrrad fahren tut
manchmal richtig gut wirklich wir sind
gefallen und das war eines der schönsten
tag in düsseldorf ihr wirklich dass das
so angenehm fahrrad zu fahren wir lassen
einfach das auto stehen und wir fahren
lieber fahrrad heute wollten wir auch
fahren aber es hat nicht geklappt weil
wir gerne aufnehmen mussten
aber ja ich wollte nur einen tipp geben
geht draußen fahrrad fahrrad das ist
wirklich gut
oder auch in köln mit christa wird und
nicht so fahrrad waren mit iphone
sondern
das wird da genießen es tut wirklich gut
manchmal und internet zu sehen jetzt ok
vielen dank jo wenn er noch mehr videos
mit youtube ansehen wollt dann zum
beispiel sicher interessant für euch das
mit sally der blog in dem er von seiner
jugend erzählt wo sie nicht mal eine
heizung hatten tatsächlich oder das
interview mit weiter
indem sie ihr großes geheimnis
lüften also wenn euch das interessiert
klickt hier und ansonsten
bist dran